what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be reacting to one of kevin samuels
live it says just wow
ig live before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification
now that way you're going to be notified
of my daily videos so um what makes me
very interesting um to listen to talk is
i actually grew up
in a two-parent household with nine
siblings
and my dad is what's considered a high
value
high value man um i mean i i can't speak
in like
every single area like some people say
that he needs to have like a six-pack
which my dad definitely doesn't but in
terms of income
definitely like top probably half a
percent
so it's just interesting to see like
what people think of like high value men
um anyways subscribe please
oh god hi mr sam hey how are you doing
oh my gosh it's my second time so
excited
okay i tell you all the time that the
young folks need to be
talking to you okay
what's your first name how old are you
my name is
zoella i'm 25. all right what do you got
for me we're talking about being capped
tonight
okay so listen a lot of people come to
your show and they really try to tell
you
that you're wrong now i don't
necessarily think you're wrong
i think that
like i think that just as far as being
capped
i feel like a lot of i feel like it's
not honestly both ways
what do you mean it goes it goes away
both ways
okay we only want to talk about the way
it goes with the women okay
because we have 50 years to talk about
the way it goes to me
okay fair enough so i feel like with us
a lot of the times like maybe we cap
about like what we want like you know
how you ask all the women what they want
and then you hit them with the three
look questions and then well now that's
not the cap
that's not i don't mean like you're
capping i've said you're capped
meaning you have a upper limit of what
you can get
okay yes i agree so take me for instance
so i'm 25 years old but i'm in a career
that i'm the youngest person
in my career you're capped at what you
can get
yeah i'd agree with that so i'm a
therapist
and a lot of the people in my career are
older than me
right and so a lot of the men that i
attract
are older than me because you know you
talked about how
the young men don't have respect for
older men so there's a learning gap
and then there's older men who are
attracted to me because i'm 25 with no
children with a career living on my own
but there's because i didn't grow up
with a man in the house necessarily
what do you think you're okay okay uh
your cat would be what
regarding relationships i would say my
account would have to be
the sexual marketplace value
i would say that that is just that is
your that is your cap
like the cap i would probably do 39
no no no no no no the kind of man
you can get the cap the top the limit i
think
listen listen listen
i'm listening to you don't do me like
that man
i'm listening i'm just literally tell me
don't tell me what to do
no i'm just asking this time just this
this let me do what i do
i've let you talk and the reason i
stepped in is because you're not on
subject
you're just talking the cap meaning
what is the top kind of man you can
qualify for
and what does the bottom mean you
qualify for and what's the average
that's the that's the key or like what i
think
well it's not about what you think
everybody has a cap and a woman's cap is
her sexual marketplace value
this is why you can be a woman with a
high school diploma
and marry a millionaire if you have a
highness smv
and you can be a woman with a phd and
and
can't get a husband because you're
unattractive
that's real that's an smd
so what what
what would your cap be i think 47.
how does she still not get the answer to
the question
he's not he's asking what he ranks she
ranks herself who's that who just came
in that car
hey say hi hey you doing
um i don't think you're understanding
the topic so i'm gonna
it's not about an age
it's about what kind of man so you said
you're a professional your therapist
do you have a bachelor's master's what a
bachelor's and i'm
going for my master's right now and how
much do you anticipate making
midway through your career by the time
you're 45 years old
about how much you think you'll be
making annually so right now
i'm making about 79 almost 80.
so midway through your career about 45
what do you think you'll be making
probably over a mil what annually
yeah because what i'm trying to do with
mental health in our community
i think people are going to accept it
more than i do
and i'm figuring everything that i'm
trying to do on the side
how many people are therapists make a
million dollars annually
well aside from what i make right now
just at a job
less what i'm going to be doing i'm not
going to work my job forever
so if i make almost okay you you can't
even have the conversation
i just asked you every question i've
asked you
you've just talked i said midway through
your career what do you think you're
going to make annually you're honestly
saying i expect to
be a millionaire as a therapist
okay good which fairy tales do come true
but that's not real that's not the rea
ma'am ma'am i talk to therapists
i i network with therapists i work with
psychiatrists psychologists phds from
ivy league
and they ain't making that kind of money
i don't
i need you to listen i need you to
listen
okay there she goes you're not going
over you're not that's
you're already on cue oh wait i'm not
trying to be rude
but what i need you to understand is you
can't even i don't want to talk about
what you want to talk about
i'm talking about what i'm talking about
my subject and i can't even get you to
understand
what you plan on making about halfway
through but let's just say you're making
a million let's just go ahead and say it
you're making a million then how much do
you do you want to get married one day
you want children yes you do how many
children would you like to have
three to four three to four uh and
do you wanna have to work to pay
significant bills after you're pregnant
with your first child after marriage
i probably will have to do you wanna
have to work to pay significant bills
after you're pregnant with your first
child when you're married
yes okay what percentage of the family
financial load do you want to have to be
responsible for for a lifetime
with four children you and a husband
what percentage overall for a lifetime
20 to 30. 20 30 so you still are looking
for a provider male
a man making enough to pay 70 to 80 of
the bills meaning if you stop working
for any reason
the family would not be significantly
impacted
how much money how much money how much
money would a man need to make
to provide for a family of four children
a wife and himself
to not have her income impact the family
in any long-term way
how much money would he need to make
annually probably 80 to 100
000
what state do you live in taxes
80 000 for six people
i grew up in the country so it doesn't
really see what i mean
they don't know their caps folks see see
this is a woman who says she
let's see i know people that make like
50 000
a year and have four kids they just live
very frugally
they live a very different lifestyle her
plan is to make a million
but i got down to the real numbers of it
she thinks a man with 80 000 will be
able to provide a middle-class lifestyle
why wouldn't he though
you said middle class math math
math because the average black men in
this country makes 50 41
500. the average i need you to
okay obviously you don't know wait wait
so i need you to live because because as
a therapist
as an educated woman and you want these
things y'all should know this stuff
you should know you should know that
it's impossible
to have a man making 80 000 and then you
not have to work
for children you guys would be lit man
it the average child takes about a
quarter of a million dollars from
age zero to 18. three children
and for you not to have to work to pay
significant bills in texas you're
talking about a man making about 300 to
350 000
a year unfortunately i swear sometimes
he doesn't think poor people exist
children add another hundred thousand
you're talking about a man making close
to four hundred thousand almost half a
mil
not eighty eighty thousand dollars
eighty thousand dollars will not pay for
four children college fund
retirement 401k medical insurance
talking about to raise a child or for
them to go past
because like i'm going to have a
conversation with the audience okay see
this is why women don't understand their
caps they don't understand their caps
because they don't even understand how
much money a man needs to make don't
even understand
what they're asking about so it's all
fantasy there's
it's all fantasy it's all fantasy it's
all fantasy for women at this point
because i can't have the conversation
with you man because
i'm talking at a different level of
understanding i'm talking about calculus
you're talking about arithmetic
i'm not i'm just asking you to okay
um i'm going to have the presentation
all right
see i couldn't even get to where i need
to get to with her and at the end of the
day
like it or not i can still do this that
woman still wants a man to pay 70 to 80
of the bills that's still a provider
male that means if you have a four leg
table one two three
a table can stand with three legs women
don't
black women in particular don't want
their money to impact the family in any
kind of way that means
as a husband you were going to have to
pay the lion's share of the bills
for a lifetime that is still a man in
the top
eighty percent even at eighty thousand
dollars
even at eighty thousand which is a
ridiculously no number
only fifteen percent of black men earned
that amount of money
and the ultimate question is
if 100 of women want men in this
area can you get one and the answer is
no damn that's what it comes down to
because your smv
height weight dress size what do you
look like a fresh face out of the shower
no makeup your natural hair
is average you can get a man making
about forty thousand dollars
forty one thousand five hundred is what
you get
as an average woman no matter how you
slice it
so this is what i want you guys to
understand that conversation
is the problem because so many women
today are in another world when it comes
it is all theory and wishes
i can make a million dollars as the
effing therapist
paging gin london esquire
i need you guys to understand this woman
said i think i'll be making a million
dollars because of the businesses i
wanted
so now you dr phil
this is why so many women are lost today
because they've never had to sit down
and understand
how much money is do am i
because they go to school they can run
up all this student loan debt let's see
most women are living just running up
bills today
and they think somebody's gonna come pay
it later on i'll get married and he'll
take care of it
ladies that ain't gonna work i don't
know why
girls are so bad with money
now i think college debt is a different
issue because i don't think a lot of 18
year olds realize what they're signing
up for um i think if i was in a
situation where i'd pay for my own
college
um i can't say like i'm 100 sure i would
have made the right decision
but i don't i've never been one to spend
money i don't have like i've never
even really had credit card debt or i
i didn't even have a credit card till
like a year ago it's like that woman i
talked to yesterday
who got a hundred thousand dollars in
student loan debt and over 150 thousand
dollars in
consumer debt and she's an english she
got an english degree
and a math teacher it all
in her mid 30s
y'all got a reality coming the reality
is
you're going to work most women 72
percent of mothers in this country work
full or part-time
unless you are bona fide eight nine or
ten
according to the what we as men think
not what you think according to what we
as men think
you can expect to work the rest of your
life
married with children
no
no
why god why
i'm kidding i swear to god i'm kidding
i actually don't even mind working
because i love what i do
actually like i could do this the rest
of my life
and that pisses a lot of women out
because like well then why do i need to
get married
because you can't afford to do it by
yourself
seven hasn't ruined everything we just
used to be able to chill at the house
not work
damn i'm just oh my gosh i hope you guys
understand it being sarcastic
unbelievable
she'll be gone i don't know why i get
like a sense of pride
from working like i'm genuinely upset at
the end of the day if i don't feel like
i accomplished everything i want to
accomplish
like i'm upset i don't like bill gates
personal thank you
thank you that's a phd uh
thank you i just got a message from a
phd
ivy league educated psychiatrist
and she's laughing at that conversation
she's like what in the french toast
yes i don't just talk
i back things up with knowledge people i
know
and i know i know professionals
who are highly degree great grades
impeccable credentials
not making a million effing dollars you
have no idea
oh i wish i could bring some of these
people on but they i want to protect
their
privacy so so many of you ladies because
so many women are overrepresented in
healthcare
women think being in healthcare means
you're going to make a lot of money
wrong it's what's pitched to you it's
what's sold to you
that's why so many women get to become
nurses or therapists and counselors and
you're in
you're you're chronically single because
you have to work crazy hours you have to
give your life to the practice
and you're not making any money because
of insurance because of the way things
are built because your patient load and
this
and that you don't want a hot box with
the godfather on this topic i know too
much
let's get it you're capped
you're capped at your sexual marketplace
value
that's where you're capped ladies that's
what everybody is where ladies are count
hello she's pretty i give her
seven but they can't do sevens i don't
know eight or six hi kevin how are you
i am well how old are you i'm 24.
have you been on here before i have
okay
my question is because you keep
referring to the average woman i wanted
to get your take on what the average
woman
is to you
like financially education-wise
job-wise all of that was an average what
is an average what is an average
what is an average woman what do you
mean what i mean what it is to me
an average woman is an average looking
woman
i think i've been pretty clear i've been
pretty clear but i'll explain again
how i'll use you as an example you're 24
any children no how tall are you
i'm five foot five foot dress size
uh i wear a five the dress size five
mm-hmm how much did you weigh the last
time you weighed yourself
i weigh 145 pounds
okay what is the average height for an
american female
5 right now i think it's
five four it's always been five four oh
it's close
five four for the last 100 plus years
what is the average weight for an
american female
it's 5'4 i don't
what's the average healthy weight
isn't the average person overweight i
thought
i i guess maybe my weight i don't know
but
i don't know so that's the problem see
these things
have been been told to you you go to a
doctor
they tell you that healthy weight are
you a healthy weight
i am yeah no
okay okay hold on hold on hold on
hold on let's just do let's just do this
okay
five foot four five foot five feet
and you said you're 145 pounds yes i
work out
uh-huh i'm going to just go ahead okay
okay okay that's good uh
your bmi is 29.3
uh according to bmi overweight is 25 to
29.9
you are point you are point six
percent away from obesity
kevin do i look on dcu i don't see
audience i want you guys to understand
she asked me what is average
well some girls just don't gain weight
around their face and i swear black
girls
they carry weight better than like white
because
i think more white girls will just have
like the gut where like black girls will
like
gain it all over but just a little and
this is the problem
women today think they can put what they
f and feel
in place of facts you are short four
inches shorter
and you are 25 pounds heavier than a
healthy
weight at your height you should be
roughly about 105 pounds
according to the bmi you are overweight
i don't care how it looks i don't care
if the fat fail where we like it so
there's one factor
so automatically in our community eighty
percent of the women
are overweight that means what above
average
or below average okay if you're
if you're overweight are you above
average
or below average
i'll be below average right so if eighty
percent of our women
are below average because fun fact
i can be i'm six foot so i can be 182
pounds and still
fall in the normal category for bmi
tall girls get leeway then we go to
their looks
what would you give yourself on the
scale from one to ten
fresh face out of the shower your
natural hair you cannot use seven
um
i don't know maybe on a regular
schmuggler [ __ ] day i'd say maybe it's
six
okay i will give you a six and a six
is cute a five is
average so if you're a cute woman
that's one step above average okay
average means average you look at your
look in your
your your family history and most people
average
right at the top of the bell curve but
if you take an
if you take a cute woman who's
overweight
that adjusts her smv up or down
down thank you so that makes her
averages that makes as those two numbers
they kind of average out
you would be an average woman and as an
average
about an average woman in this country
an average black woman
the average black man in this country
earns 41
500 for a lifetime
no more no less no herculean methods
no lottery no businesses that's what
he's going to make
that's your husband what if i have
degrees oh look at her she's so sad look
at her eyes
thank you see see
i want you guys to understand she just
asked me and i told her
what is a woman has her smv now
these women actually think because they
can make themselves
higher smb because of a degree
that does not work
men have never picked women based upon
your degree
that is why you could be on fries at
mcdonald's but if you look like
kelly rowland you can marry a
millionaire
but you could graduate from harvard but
if you look like precious
you ain't got no income why do you think
a degree should matter to your
sexual marketplace value um
i think it should add just because i
mean if you're going based off
disappearances
i'm going based upon who men are
when if men ever said look at that
average looking woman but god damn i bet
you she got a degree
oh that ain't no ma'am no
breathe you gotta ask the customer
the men and that just shows that you
ladies don't understand
what we are that is who we are
we don't care about your degree until we
care about how you look in your body
that's that's when it matters after your
smv
so that that's the question why worry
about your degree
why don't i why not bump your s b up if
you want a higher caliber husband
uh-oh get a personal trainer that's what
i did
so every other group of women does they
understand what the men want and they
give the men what they want
so when you lose weight
no no dress size four 110 105 pounds
dress size 4 100 510 pounds
just high school because you gotta have
some room to grow because at five foot
you have one two kids that's going every
child
30 to 50 pounds you have three kids your
husband can expect
oh my god i'm just getting 30 to 50
pounds with every kid
no no i gotta i got i'm a diet or some
woman
coming in close to 200 pounds after
three kids
you gotta have some room to grow you're
150 pounds already
pregnancy weight is 30 to 50 pounds you
got pregnant with one kid
you'll go up to 180 on the low end 200
as the normal
you're not going to lose all that weight
have another kid
another 30 to 50. another kid another 30
to 50.
even if you average that out you're
gonna gain another 30 pounds in
childbirth
that means you go from 150 to 180
foot 180 is almost 200 pounds that is a
large
woman but that is what you see wobbling
around the black community
all the time below average
smv women and they
and do you see many wedding rings on
those
nope but then you wonder why you see
becky and miley running and eating
drinking water and eating salads but
what you see on that finger
so you think even you see on their thing
let's be honest becky drinks starbucks
look kevin let's give credit where
credit is due
becky drinks starbucks irene i
get that yeah but but we need to see it
because it makes it real
okay so even with today's culture with
you know
people desiring and paying for more
curvaceous curves you know boob jobs
uh butt lifts everything you still think
that
men are desiring skinnier women
have you been how long have you watched
my channel for some time
and every time you see those
ridiculously uh
curvy women they're unmarried
some are some aren't no they're not
they're they're mostly unmarried i've
already addressed this conversation
i addressed this on the joe budden
podcast i addressed this on
um uh vlad tv and i addressed this on
adam no jumper that's for fun
men don't marry that so how about this
you notice how every time i say what men
are instead of just saying
hmm i'll go do that and so why not why
don't why don't you accept this
men are asking women to go get brazilian
butt lifts we ain't asking for yellow
where we
this is what i always say there's a
difference between sexual attention
and wifey attention a guy will give you
sexual attention
i should do a video on this a guy will
give you sexual attention if he's just
dating you for now um but he has no
intention of marrying you
and i that's what i see a lot when girls
are gonna like post their thoughts on
instagram and like present themselves a
certain way
you know what kind of attention are you
getting and same with like the bbl's
boob jobs
we're not asking for y'all having long
acrylic nails and all these
flippy eyelashes y'all doing that for
each other we don't like that
we want them on good times we want pam
grier that's what we want
but then what you're giving me you don't
and once it's proven
you don't really care what men want and
that's why you're not getting with me
you're not getting husbands you're
getting sex
and some of y'all get babies
but do you get the question do you
understand what an average woman is
yeah you answer my question so if that's
the case and
and an average woman an average people
should get average people above average
people or high level people
average people get average people
assortative mating so why is it that
most
average women don't want average men
because it's a natural thing for people
to want what they can't have
it's not it's not natural it's not
natural it's natural desire
no it's not no it's not no no ma'am it's
not natural
it is not natural every other race a
woman on here is
black white women are the next lowest
group of married women they're married
to 54 or eight
and you look at an average looking white
woman and you're like ooh even the women
who are unattractive you're like ooh
but you look on her finger and like
she's married like who would marry her
you look at her husband and they look
like they met
that's so true that's so true because
they accept
but in our community women want the men
to look better than them
it's not natural black women are living
an unnatural existence you're living
opposite to nature
you're living opposite to even the god
you say you believe in in creation
it's rather devilish as a matter of fact
you just look at the outcomes man it's
not a matter of black men either
it's not as though any other group of
men are rushing to marry
are women who is marrying black women
i mean mostly black men and a small
population of other races but okay
and the black women are married at a
rate of one out of four
and the next lowest group of women is
married at a rate of 54
that's almost double yeah
do you see a problem there that is a
problem
and who is it on to fix it
black people you notice how she did that
notice how she did that she said it's on
black people so that means we're
supposed to be in this to fix it with
them black men
[ __ ] it's not on black people to fix
black women's problems
it's on black women can i can i
interject i said black people because
it's not just a woman's problem yes it
is
yes it is yes it is because i said who's
no you can't no no
no i said who's rushing to marry black
women meaning of
any group of men no one
so why is it black men's responsibility
to fix you to make you a white man's
wife
i hear you kevin let me get to my point
my point is
that if black men are the ones that are
you know picking us to marry us and
they're the ones that are seeing these
issues
it's it's not just starting when oh
she's of age
to start dating and things like that it
goes to a woman's self-esteem which
usually rooted from her father and
there's man no no no no no no no
no you're an adult you're you're an
you're an adult and an individual
you're responsible for your choices see
look at that look at this people
understand something i said man what
which men are rushing to marry black
women
and what you're trying to get me to say
is that it's black men's responsibility
to work with black women hand hold you
to make you marriageable
for other men as well no ma'am
it is your responsibility at the bottom
to make yourself
viable to any group of men black men
included okay and then i have
so who raises a black man black women
okay so therefore we are teaching excuse
me
who raises who black women raise black
men
black women raised women raised the
children i understand
but my point is black women raise black
men
so black women set that talk that tone
and that standard
for that black man of what they want and
what they are looking for
a lot of black men man what are you
trying to make stop stop stop
stop stop stop black women
raise children 80 of the children are
born out of wedlock
they raise black children right and
black men
black men aren't having a problem
finding
mates only black women
y'all got the problem see
you asked about average and i gave it to
you you did
and every time i try to give you a
solution you want accountability to be
on everybody else except the woman in
the mirror
no i no that's so true girls
they do not like be sorry i had to text
my friend since i was looking down but i
swear i was listening
no girls literally they never want to be
held accountable
and never want any actual feedback i i'm
someone i like genuinely like feedback
because it helps you be more realistic
but most girls like
i don't know they do not want to be told
stuff i said it was black
people i didn't i didn't think that's
that's like
yesterday saying black people means it's
black men
as well
that means it's taking accountability
from the woman in the mirror
okay
it is a black woman's issue it is so why
do black men need to fix
it we're not even first of all we don't
want y'all the way you are we've been
telling you all my life y'all ain't
listening to what we say so we're just
lifting to your own devices
and no one's taking you this way
the problem is black women lack
accountability for their choices you're
a free
person you can make your choices and you
are free to win
you're free to lose you're free to fail
or free to succeed
yet what you're doing is not working
with any group of men
no group of men is rushing to say ooh i
need to get a black woman but black men
even being at the bottom
socioeconomically well above hispanic
men
black boys reading on the fourth grade
level black men aren't doing well but
they're the second most desired male on
the planet behind white men
and why do you think that is because we
got our [ __ ] together
we're desired like it or not here's the
thing honest seriously though
because we understand our real place the
world tells black men
you ain't good enough where you got to
work you haven't been told
you got to work you've been told you're
a queen you're good you ain't got to do
nothing
to where honestly ma'am i want you to
find me many five feet tall
chinese women who weigh as much as you
do
that's a different culture they don't no
it's not that's a different it's a
different
culture but i want you to go back in
your family album
to the to the 1910s and i want you to
find me a women who weighed as much as
you do
that's your height
we don't weigh this much you can go to
soul train in 1970 and see what
what y'all used to look like
soul train i don't know i don't lick my
weight but i understand what you're
saying
you can't make it up see this is what
shahara's out there
a couple weeks ago where i realized that
i was overweight
um not that much surprisingly like i'm
six foot so if i'm at 180
i'm technically in like the normal range
for bmi you don't
have to believe me you could look it up
but i'd like to have like a little room
to like
gain so i'm trying to lose like i'm
trying to get to 160.
but i don't look that big so i never
really have because
i have a little stomach but that's
pretty easy to hide with like a dress or
something
so i've never really been like in
society considered that overweight
but yeah once i started watching the
show and realizing this i hired a
personal trainer like literally that
week
it's been safe black women have been
shielded from the consequences
accountability and everything else it's
a different culture it's this effect
your body is not meant to be your weight
at your height
that's why you that's why you are fat
where you shouldn't be
this is the only time in history where
the poor people
weigh more than the rich people that's
so true
that's so true
wait you were saying fat in general or
were you directing that towards my
weight
i'm talking about in general okay in
general but but even at you
five feet ma'am you're not supposed to
be 150 pounds
you're not i work more than you weigh
you way more than a man at your height
and that is one of the biggest problems
in our community
if you take the average black woman and
if you put a black man next to her
side by side the average black woman at
her
height weighs more than the black man at
his height
meaning a five foot four black man
and a five foot four black women most
women are going to weigh more
you live in texas go to the mall and
look at all the number 10 couples you
see where the man is like this and a
woman is like this well that's why
women can get away with it because i
always say this women
90 of the time no matter how big they
are can still find husbands
or guys to date them yes
you see it all the time i know i do
and why why is it because because y'all
don't know that y'all need to
drink water cut back on the sugar fat
and salt work out
yeah y'all haven't heard this just don't
it's like well somebody somewhere will
take it
and they know that's true i don't know
where taking it because somebody's
having
not completely false sex with women
yeah okay fair enough
but i don't know i think most girls can
find someone to marry them it's just not
someone they're attracted to but the
bottom line is this
if we are keeping score by marriages
right
the one thing that we can keep score by
arguing black women are at the bottom
that's marrying anybody one in four
will marry
that's a crisis that's a crisis
but it who is it but again
who is it who does it fall upon to fix
it if the next
lowest group of women is married at a
rate of 54
almost twice as much
who's it who's it to fall upon it falls
upon black women
right so why don't you go ask white
women what to do or hispanic women what
to do or asian what to do because
apparently they seem to know how to do
something
typically if you're not doing something
right and somebody's making better great
if somebody's making better grades than
you are
you go ask them how to do it
but they copying us they copying black
women
where they get their nails done they do
get butt lifts
you want bigger breasts bigger lips okay
let's let's run with that
then if that's the case why are they
more married than y'all
damn that's a good question
because they ain't copying y'all
no that's what i'm saying they copy
certain looks and features
but there's things that other
communities copy from white people
or asian people it doesn't mean they're
copying the whole culture
you don't think so now they may be
copying a look but the software is
different
the femininity the attitude the
accountability
the desiring to please your men cater to
your men submit
i just said go ask the women who are
doing better than you and the first
thing you said
that's right that no no listen to my
point
the first time i said go to the women
who were giving me a better outcome
and you said no they are checking for us
and that's why y'all are dying
alone so is it really
what you call it an svdsv what you call
it smv
is it really smv or is it attitude
adjustment
men are visual your sexual marketplace
value is the thing that we look at first
and then after we like that then we'll
see if we want to tolerate you longer
than a night
see what black women are doing right now
will get you a lot of sex
y'all got no problem becoming hot girl
summoning
and you know hooking up and swiping up
but you got problems with his long-term
relationships and that's a matter of who
you are
after the bedroom that's true
so why don't you go ask the women who
can keep men
why don't you go ask the women who can
get husbands
because if it's not in our community
you go to the people who make a better
grades right
if the p if you're in your school or
your group
and everybody's failing and
right over there they're passing or
doing twice as good
do you keep going to people over here or
do you go and ask people who are doing
better
the reasonable thing would be to go ask
somebody who's doing better
why do you need to put well you need to
put the modifier there guys funny thing
my friend is literally texting me right
now and asking me about kevin samuels
and like basically his concepts like i
was telling her about like the
adjustable like
five six seven or whatever
and yeah and it's funny because
now i'm like literally telling my
friends about these
because i have my own opinion i hear
what you're saying about him
and that's my point and saying folks i
just want you to understand that's why i
want my critics and detractors to
understand it's not a matter of
information
shame insults guilt and the need to
be right is the primary motivating
factor for most black women
they need to be right in our way so it
doesn't matter if you can point them to
what's right
and what's better i'm gonna be all right
doing it my way that's why i'm waiting
for jesus or god or somebody else
kevin i'm not saying that you're wrong
i'm just saying that i would
agree to disagree we have a difference
no there's no agree to disagree agree to
disagree but here's the problem
black women are failing at getting
husbands
there's no agree to disagree there's no
agree to disagree you're dying alone
there's no agree to disagree
that's a that's a that is an attitude
that you can't afford to have
how do you how can you afford to agree
to disagree unless you can get a better
outcome
let me ask you this let me ask you this
okay
are you do you want to be married i will
be married one day yes
okay you want children um i'm 24 years
old so i haven't decided
i was 24 years old have to do with
anything
i'm still young and
living my life i i don't guys i swear to
god i did not pay her i did not pay her
y'all cannot this is the problem they
think their 20s are for them
she thinks she's been programmed to
think my 20s are for me so it
late 20s and 30s then i'll decide
whether or not i want to have kids
and it's too late by that time as of
right now i don't
i i don't want kids right now but when
i'm older i would like to have
older how much older um once i finish my
master's so maybe
26 27 26 27 that's two years
away that's fine
all right and you want to be married are
you being actively vetted by a man of
value to be his wife
um i have are you being actively vetted
by a man of value to be his wife
yes are you in a relationship right now
no i'm not then you're not actively
being vetted by a man of value to be his
wife
will you i mean okay okay
stop the cap they can't deal with
reality
you saw that going off the rails i'm too
young i'm too this up to that
if you think like that young lady stop
i'll go get my masters i'm too young to
be worried about kids
after my master's when is that two years
you wanna be married yet one day are you
actively being vetted by
a man of value to be his wife yeah i am
are you in a relationship
no
you do realize that we can see you lying
right
just lying
and wonder well it's only black man to
help us
fix black man can't fix that
no no no no no
oh my
yeah mama
it's our job to fix that guys did you
know
no i it's genuinely in our control and
this is i'm literally texting my friend
about this
right now um
because you know your whole life you're
told like
oh there's that one person waiting out
there for you and so i think girls
naturally because they've been told that
have like fallen back and just like
waited for it
but when kevin says okay this is what
you gotta do you gotta be fit
feminine and friendly it's like oh so
it's in my control
it's not the world it's it's me it's
at least like comforting because
you can figure out how to do that but i
don't know typically
when i was growing up like nobody told
me that black man
it is your job to go talk to a woman
who don't even value your opinion and
don't even care what you want right now
don't even care what you want right now
but it's your job to go make sure that
she can get her stuff together
so she can be somebody else's wife one
day
ah he can't make this [ __ ] up folks
you cannot make this [ __ ] up when i get
my phd
or my masters when i get my masters when
i get my masters
boy howdy if master's degrees was
husbands
if a master's degree was a husband
and a life some of y'all would be the
[ __ ]
when i get my masters i get my masters
i get my masters then i'm gonna get my
stuff together
hello it's kevin
[Music]
how are you okay uh
how old are you i'm 24. uh you have
people in the background
yeah this is my sister you mind going to
a room where it's not
a little bit more quiet yes i can give
me that thank you
all right so folks understand i just
have the conversations
and yes okay
so we're talking about being capped
today
being cast
no capped meaning there's an upper limit
and a lower limit on the kind of guy you
can get
okay on your life everybody has an upper
limit and a lower level
okay do you think that's true
uh upper limit and lower limit i think
so yes
all right i don't know the light is
weird back there
okay wait okay go ahead there it is okay
so
do you have any children no no children
all right and move your face up a little
bit your camera's right
yeah okay so yeah there's an upper limit
and a lower limit um
what do you think what do you think what
do you think determines
a woman's limit on the dating market
her possible talent pool of men
um i think it depends on like her money
her money herself are like who she
places herself around
okay uh let me refer to it as the
ceiling and the floor seeing as a limit
okay so you think referred to the
ceiling and the floor
is her money i would say
you said okay so you're saying like the
type of man that she dates
you know the kind of man you can get
what's what determines the floor
of the men you can get the bottom and
then the ceiling the top
that's like the top it definitely like
looks is that is that where you're
pertaining to
like how you look how you carry yourself
i'm just trying yeah i i know what it is
i'm trying to see how many women
understand
i really don't know like i i need to
like be more
and hear how it again play more i'm
sorry
you're howard again i'm 24. were you
raised with your mom and dad or just
your mom
uh just my mom um how many siblings do
you have
um i have four siblings uh i'll buy you
i all your mother
yes so it's five of y'all yes
how many different fathers i would say
two three
it's three of us me and my brother have
the same brother my sister has her own
dad and then
my twin sisters have the same dad okay
do you want to do you want to be married
one day
of course okay
um well have you ever asked your mom why
she chose not to get married
my mom actually wants to get married but
i think it's just like the men that she
chose
she no no no no i asked her if you and
she'll ask your mom why she chose not to
get married
no i haven't actually asked her why she
hasn't chosen to got married get married
you had a conversation with your mother
yeah because at 24
you said you need information well
you're supposed to get it from your
parents
right your mother's had five children
and she's had at least three men
right but no husbands right
no i agree but so i would ask her why
are you making babies without husbands
mom
because apparently she thinks this is
the way
why do you think it is um i personally
believe that
like going with that potential or like
that
if i know what like my father they were
just like young
and they had kids and stuff like that
but i think as she got older i think she
saw that possibly she can get married to
these people but then of course
like no no no your mom
there's a book called promises i can
keep while women choose
marriage over i mean motherhood over
marriage
none of that that's a nice way of making
your mom
unaccountable um right your mama knew
right from wrong
and your mama having five children with
no husband
is wrong as hell yeah so i'm gonna move
on because it's not your mama because
you can't ask it for no good
yeah at the end of the day a man
is a visual creature we evaluate women
on your sexual marketplace value that
means your physique
and your looks right and then after that
other things tend to come in place after
that
but that's what we pick on so what
determines the floor
is how uh
ugly you are yeah and what determines
the ceiling
is how pretty you are yeah so that's
kind of what i said like looks i feel
like it's like top
for sure looks as looks is the floor in
the ceiling
yeah okay
the woman i just had on yeah
she asked the question well what about
can you raise your your value
because you have a degree you know guys
do not
care about your degree i mean i think
some guys
um might care just because it shows
discipline but they're more attracted to
like
a girl that shows discipline rather than
the degree
i don't think that i don't think that
personally matters
nope yeah it doesn't it doesn't
work no one asks you like you know you
can talk to a guy no maybe i said oh
what school you want to
and stuff like that but if you had your
head's kind of cut off
your head's good if you had your like
ged or your phd it doesn't matter
so so who whose child was that any other
oh that's my sister's baby your hands
are still halfway out oh
sorry sorry how how does your sister
uh my sister's actually 19.
i know i i did the rock back too when
are you on birth control
no are you sexually active
yes ma'am get on birth control
i agree no no no no no no no don't
i'ma just say what a father should say
your mother has taught you wrong
yeah and your sister
is a there's a teenage mother and that's
a cycle
right have sex i'm not saying i mean if
you're gonna have sex just don't make
any babies
oh yeah i tell my sister that all the
time i'm talking to you
i'm not talking to you so i'm talking
i'm not worried about your sister i'm
talking to you
okay listen yeah don't oh yeah me listen
okay okay
you come from women who are reckless
and i'm calling it as i see it your
mother was reckless
your sister is reckless and this yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah stuff
is too much if you're going to have sex
have protection go get an iud
and go get iud's the best form of birth
plan b
as a backup oh yeah and then use condoms
there's more than just pregnancy oh yeah
there's sexually transmitted diseases
oh yeah i'm already know i'm saying yes
because i totally agree with you that's
what i'm telling you like good
good because the one thing that could
screw you up more than anything else
is having a baby and when i hear young
ladies who come from
women who with five kids or three
different dads and then
your sister got a kid
you how many sisters do you have i'm
have three sisters
how many brothers funny because my mom
was a teen mom
she my dad got her pregnant after three
months
but then they gave up that kid for
adoption and got married like five years
later
i have one brother i don't think they
hadn't known each other that long
so you know that's why right so
your holidays look like a bunch of damn
women and kids
any of your other sisters have children
oh no no
good yeah all right make don't make any
babies
don't make any babies um
i don't know that was actually pretty
interesting sorry
i know i didn't talk as much as i
normally do on my videos i was literally
texting my friend about kevin samuels
um yeah i don't know i think that
it's actually like good that he gives
you like a cheat sheet and i don't know
why more women aren't more receptive to
it
and i even asked my dad the other day
like what attracted him to my mom
and he actually gave pretty similar
answers to kevin samuels what he says on
his show so
let me know in the comments if you guys
agree or you disagree don't forget
to subscribe to the channel and bring
that notification bell and i will talk
to you guys
next time